[Music]
on this tuesday night as cobit 19 cases
multiply restrictions mount
and so does defiance our etobicoke
location will be opening
for in-restaurant dining against
provincial orders
new pandemic protocols and please to get
with the program
what are we going to be left with if we
don't get ourselves out of this dumpster
fire
canada's vaccine timeline the logistics
the contracts
and the promises we'll get it but we
won't be first
to go home for the holidays or be
homesick
my parents are really upset the dilemma
for canadians living abroad
and two years worth of rain in two days
a powerful cyclone soaks somalia
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
one month before christmas eve and with
covet 19 cases surging the message from
public health experts
is limit who you come into contact with
and tonight alberta's premier who for
weeks has resisted pleas to impose tough
restrictions
has declared a public health emergency
alberta has the most
active cases of covid19 in canada more
than 1100 new cases were reported there
today and
16 more people died and yet it has done
the least to curb
the spread today jason kenney announced
effective immediately indoor
social gatherings are prohibited and
kids in grade 7 to 12 will move to
remote learning on november 30th
heather urich's west has been listening
to the premier's late afternoon news
conference heather
what else is covered by this public
health emergency
well you covered the main points and
really what's notable is what's not
covered here
no businesses other than concert halls
community centers
and conference centers will be asked to
close
restaurants will be allowed to remain
open bars
you can still get your hair cut you'll
still be able to go to stores
you'll still be able to go to church so
we're really looking at some
targeted measured restrictions here
not at all the the wide scale lockdown
that many in the medical community have
been calling for
edmonton's royal alexandra hospital is
now seeing
more and more patients sick with covid19
this is happening i mean i worked last
night i saw it with my own eyes we have
so many more covert patients in the
emergency department we have so many
more
cova patients in the intensive care
units we are there and this is just the
beginning
for weeks doctors like shasma bentani
have been calling on the province to
take action to stop the disease's
rampant spread
late tuesday afternoon alberta's premier
acknowledged how serious the situation
in alberta has become
as we increase that capacity it comes at
a
real cost a cost to people's health and
i fear a cost to people's lives
schools for grades 7 through 12 will
close to in-person learning after
november 30th
and all indoor social gatherings are now
banned but other than concert halls and
conference centers
no businesses will have to close we
believe these are the
minimum restrictions needed right now to
safeguard our health care system
while avoiding widespread damage to
people's livelihoods we are
doing everything we can to meet to
strike that balance
the alberta government has not done any
modeling since the spring
but a university of calgary researcher
has looked at the numbers
accurately predicting a month ago where
we'd be
right now i've seen that they form
exponential growth
which is what this virus does and
and fitted them to the exponential curve
and by this i could calculate the
parameters
here the doubling time according to her
analysis of the data as of last thursday
cases in alberta were doubling every
three weeks
meaning left unchecked the province
could see 2200 daily cases by december 8
and 4 400 by just after christmas but
perhaps
more troubling is what's happening in
icus as of november 19
icu hospitalizations were doubling every
two weeks
meaning alberta is likely to hit
capacity in just days
honestly i'm already scared about the
coming weeks we have missed the boat on
this
we should have put in more restrictions
two three weeks ago
and heather jason kenny has avoided
ordering non-essential businesses to
close the way other jurisdictions have
done
why does he think that's not necessary
well donnie he spoke at length during
this press conference about wanting to
strike a balance and he said that
closing businesses and imposing a
lockdown would be a
wide scale infringement upon fundamental
rights
so the question now is will these
measures be enough
we have seen in other jurisdictions how
half measures
aren't able to bring the curve down and
that really is
the fear that this won't bend the curve
in a situation that is becoming
increasingly serious here
donna all right heather urix west in
calgary tonight thank you
british columbia has again shattered its
daily record of covet 19 cases the
province recorded 941
new infections in 24 hours 10 more
people have died and hospitals in bc are
filling up too
61 people are now in intensive care
the pandemic rules vary from region to
region
and some canadians are not only ignoring
them they're encouraging others
to break them come on guys
enough is enough we're opening for
anybody who's a fan of freedom
and sovereignty the right to choose what
you wear
where to go who to have over at your
house
this restaurant owner defied toronto's
lockdown
to in-person dining today he got a crowd
of supporters but also a visit
from the police and bylaw officers and
late this afternoon
toronto's medical officer of health
ordered his restaurant
shut down meantime in nova scotia where
37 new cases were reported today the
restaurant association
actually called for all restaurants and
bars in halifax to close
to dine in customers today the premier
agreed and as of midnight wednesday
halifax restaurants moved to take out
only gyms art galleries and casinos must
close
too organized sports must stop and
gatherings are limited
to just five people going forward
there will be stronger enforcement for
illegal gatherings
including a thousand dollar fine for
every person who walks
through the door we're doing it early to
get out in front of this
if we look at where it's happened in the
rest of the province they've instituted
these tough measures
far later on
manitoba's premier brian pallister is
making no apologies for keeping his
entire province under tight restrictions
476 new cases were reported in manitoba
today and 12 more people have died
no gatherings with people outside your
household are allowed and
unlike in quebec there is no plan to
lift that over christmas
i think it's dangerous
what the quebec premiers decided to
announce on on christmas
i'm not trying to deprive people of a
wonderful christmas i'm trying to make
sure that this year we define
christmas differently
manitoba is cracking down on those who
break the rules nine businesses have
been fined five thousand dollars each
and more than fifty individuals got
tickets for more than twelve hundred
dollars
as marnie blunt reports those who are
sick and who have watched loved ones die
can't believe how uncaring some people
are
hospitalizations reaching new heights
intensive care units bordering on
capacity
and more manitobans losing loved ones to
coven 19.
it's not something you ever want to have
to do
to say that you're ready to let your
loved one go
that's pretty hard you know like we're
never ready but it was time
jen lambert's 80 year old mother passed
away due to covet 19
this month lambert has also tested
positive for the virus
the thing that i found the hardest was
not
being able to just touch my mom's hand
and had i known at the time that i was
positive i just would have said to hell
with it and taken my glove off
and attached my mom's hand the dire
situation in manitoba
has the province tightening restrictions
on who you can gather with
and which businesses can stay open and
what they can sell
so we can't have these number of cases
these number of deaths that we report to
be our norm
we have to act now but despite
restrictions in place
some still aren't getting the message
the province issuing 95 tickets in the
past week
equaling about 125 thousand in fines
it's not about the money it's about
preventing situations
that hurt people for lamborgh she says
it's time for everyone to move forward
together yes we want to see our loved
ones yes we want to get together for
drinks with the girls yes we want to
let our kids get together but what are
we going to be left with
if we don't get ourselves out of this
dumpster fire that we're in right now
manitoba's top doctor did offer a slight
glimmer of hope this week
saying the number of contacts per case
is coming down
something he hopes will reflect in our
numbers in a week to 10 days
donna okay marty blunt in winnipeg
thanks well vaccines are coming and
canada has signed contracts to buy them
there are no facilities here to produce
them though as abigail beeman explains
canadians will likely have to wait until
next year to roll up their sleeves we've
signed a deal to secure
up to 26 000 doses of a therapeutic drug
from eli lilly the newly approved
covid19
treatment was made in partnership with
vancouver firm abcellara
distinctly canadian liberals are trying
to focus on how great made in canada
solutions are for the pandemic
but vaccines can't be made in canada and
the opposition hammered on that the
united states and
england have announced plans to roll out
vaccines as early as next week
but what's the plan in canada how many
more months will it take
to flatten the curve because this prime
minister has been
unable to rapidly secure a vaccine
we recognize the disadvantage that
canada has of
not having a domestic pharmaceutical
industry able to create
to mass-produce vaccines the prime
minister says that disadvantage is why
canada bought more doses of vaccines in
development than most other countries
this summer the government announced 126
million dollars to build a vaccine
manufacturing center in montreal
we aren't sitting on our heels the
procurement minister promises when
vaccines eventually come to canada
canada will be ready to distribute them
with freezers gauze dry ice and other
purchases underway
we have the capacity to store up to 33.5
million ultra frozen and frozen vaccines
ontario's premier was happy with
procurement today with rapid tests now
deployed in some long-term care homes
and hospitals in that province
i was up here jumping and screaming for
two months to get these done so i want
to thank health candidate
but the looming vaccine question remains
when
when when i can't tell you the precise
timing neither the top doctor nor the
top politician would say
when they'll be approved or accessible
it
is premature to start you know crossing
out circling dates on a calendar
trudeau says canada expects to receive
doses in the first few months of 2021
but he won't get any more specific
abigail beeman global news
ottawa american thanksgiving is on
thursday
and this year it's hard to find hope the
coronavirus has infected more than 12
and a half
million americans in just over 10 months
it has killed more than 259
000 americans nearly 20 percent of the
global death toll
records are breaking every day right now
the seven day average of daily cases is
more than 173 thousand
and more than 85 000 americans are
hospitalized with covid right now that's
a record too
and nurses and doctors are exhausted
you'd think those numbers
and all those deaths would make
americans think twice before traveling
for thanksgiving
some are staying home but millions of
others are on the move
jackson proskow reports
they were warned not to travel or gather
this thanksgiving
millions of americans are doing it
anyway i was a little anxious
i'm very very paranoid when it comes to
traveling especially during covid
because it's just
a scary situation to be in u.s airports
have seen their highest passenger
volumes since the spring
more than a million passengers per day
doctors see a disaster in the making
my concern is that people just don't
realize how quickly
this spreads and how easily it spreads
most of the patients that i take care of
will tell me that they don't feel like
they did anything that was overtly risky
case numbers are now surging in 48
states
the spread of the virus is described as
aggressive and rapid according to
internal white house documents
we could have avoided some of what we're
seeing right now if we would have done
more stringent types of measures all
those cases will inevitably lead to more
hospitalizations
in many states the system is already at
the breaking point
on average one american now dies of
covid 19
every minute of every day it's just
waring
to come in and take care of these people
and see a lot of people just not taking
this seriously
outside of here if only they could see
what was going on
in north dakota nurses from the air
force have been brought in to help with
the crush of patients
other hospitals are converting
specialized medical units into covid
wards
our heart failure unit we had to convert
it to a covid unit that means all those
heart failure patients are being moved
elsewhere
away from the nurses that are specially
trained in heart failure to date more
than 12
million americans have been infected
estimates are that number will nearly
double by the time
joe biden is inaugurated as president in
january
job one for the new president will be
taming the virus and distributing a
vaccine
work that will come too late to spare
the u.s from a dark winter of pain
jackson proskow global news washington
news that the transition from the trump
to the biden administration is underway
perked up the stock market the dow jones
topped 30
000 points for the first time in its
history and it's on course
for its best month since 1987. president
donald trump took
credit for that in brief remarks at the
white house today
and his successor president-elect joe
biden revealed his picks for key cabinet
posts
the team includes the first woman
director of national intelligence avril
haynes
veteran diplomat linda thomas greenfield
has been named u.s
ambassador to the united nations
alejandro mayorkas is poised to be the
first latino to head the department of
homeland security
and biden's top foreign policy advisor
anthony blinken
is set to be secretary of state john
kerry a former obama-era secretary of
state and former presidential candidate
will be the first ever presidential
envoy on climate change
all of them will have to be confirmed by
the senate
under fire and under investigation
coming up what french police are being
accused of after breaking up a migrant
camp
[Applause]
police in france used force to clear out
a makeshift migrant camp in the heart of
paris today
officers used tear gas and pushed their
way in people were
tossed out of tents which police say
were illegally set up
hundreds of people were displaced
critics say it was excessive use of
force the french interior minister
called it shocking
and has ordered the police chief to
provide a full report the outcry is
happening while the french president
tries to pass strict new security laws
that beef up police powers
opponents say they restrict civil
liberties
the strongest tropical cyclone ever
recorded in the northern indian ocean
has slammed into somalia
cyclone gaddy has triggered landslides
and flooding along the country's
northeastern coast
the storm intensified quickly and it's
the strongest to hit somalia
two years worth of rain is expected in
two days in the driest part of the
country
at least four people have been killed
cyclone gaddy packed sustained winds of
168 kilometers an hour
threat to national security ahead
allegations of funds being funneled into
canada
from iran
canada's spy agency csis is
investigating alleged attempts by iran
to secretly wire millions of dollars
into this country in violation of
international sanctions
global news has obtained documents that
point to money being funneled from iran
to a toronto currency exchange
owned by an iranian expat as mike delay
reports the money may have been used to
conduct
foreign influence behind the massive
doors of his north toronto mansion
iranian expat ali reza ongaei lives a
life of privilege
but since arriving in canada in 2008 his
attempts at gaining canadian citizenship
have been put on hold
as the canadian security intelligence
service looks into his business dealings
documents obtained by global news show
csis is investigating ongai for
assisting the government of iran in the
clandestine wiring of monies into canada
the csis report alleges the money came
from bank saterat
which the u.s treasury alleges iran uses
to fund hamas and hezbollah
ceases assesses the funds to be in the
millions
but for what purpose if the information
in
the report is true it is unique in the
sense that
often when we talk about threat related
activities with financing
it is outside of canada so individuals
sending money outside of canada
often to support violent extremist
groups but in this case with clandestine
foreign influence it may very well be
activity inside of canada
the united nations began imposing
sanctions on iran in 2006
in response to its nuclear program
canada imposed additional sanctions in
2010
the same year ongai opened ong currency
exchange in toronto
to get around the sanctions ongei
admitted to css that money was
transferred first from iran
to the uae before making its way to
canada
and into ong's accounts cesares wrote
that
ongai knows circumventing economic
sanctions is clearly illegal
and that he admitted he'd been doing it
for three years
ongae told global news he doesn't
support the iranian regime
and that the money was transferred for
clients toronto lawyer and human rights
activist kaveh sharooz
says there's been rumors in the iranian
community about vast sums of money
arriving in canada for the purpose
of influencing canadian foreign policy
and unfortunately what they're finding
is that
you know the iranian regime extends its
tentacles into canada
after ong's registration was revoked in
2012
ongai became sole director of a company
that sells surgical equipment
his finances remain a mystery his first
wife told the court in divorce
proceedings he was worth
25 million dollars while he claimed to
have earned as little as 7 500 in annual
income
and while his latest appeal for
citizenship was dismissed on november
9th
he told global news he plans to continue
fighting
microlight global news toronto
there is a lot more detail on this
complex story you can read stuart bell
and sam cooper's investigation on our
website globalnews.ca
global national christmas plights next
canadians abroad consider their options
for the holidays
it's hard to tell loved ones i won't be
home for christmas but millions of
canadians are not making travel plans
for the holidays
as tired as we are of being told to find
new ways to celebrate
this is going to be a quarantine kind of
christmas
if you can gather at all it will be in
small groups
and for canadians living overseas it's
just not worth the trip
or the risk redmond shannon spoke to
some of them
the one christmas wish for many
canadians who live in britain
is simply to get back home i've been in
tears several times
over the past month or two about not
being able to go
um my parents are really upset um my
whole family is and we've been trying to
figure out ways
to make this work and it's just it's not
possible
and we understand it and we understand
why this will be megan lahren's
first christmas away from her family in
kitchener she doesn't want to put her
parents at risk
and she can't work remotely so
quarantining twice
makes traveling impossible christmas is
a big deal for us
and to not be able to be there um it's
it's really
i think it's specially hitting my mom
quite hard my mom and my dad
instead she'll spend the holidays with
her boyfriend's family
in england edwina lowe however is flying
from london to vancouver on december 5th
to begin two weeks of isolation as my
birthday present my mom's booked me
a hotel to quarantine in my aunt is
um had cancer a couple years ago so
obviously i knew that i couldn't
quarantine with them
low has been saving up all of her
holidays this year
for the holidays well i'm gonna cry no
um well my mom is like my hero she's a
single mom she raised me and
my brother on our own during the
pandemic dave matthews has been
organizing
zoom meet-ups for canadians in london
some people
are there every week right and people
need to talk and i believe it's
very important you know a lot of people
especially during this time
they mister family they miss her friends
they miss going out and
meeting people and you know mental
health
uh is a big issue during this pandemic
you know some people underestimate it
matthews is isolating back in canada for
health reasons
but is still making sure an extra london
meeting happens on christmas day
so that canadian immigrants don't end
this loneliest of years
feeling alone redmond shannon global
news
london and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's
york canada
are these stunning images of the
northern lights captured by viewers
across the country
canada offers some of the world's best
views of the aurora borealis
it's caused by particles blasted out
from the sun colliding with gases in
earth's atmosphere
but you can put all that science aside
and just consider them
magical thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye